starting pitcher for the cubs uh
right-hander tyler chatwood third season
in a cubs uniform last year
38 appearances most out of the bullpen
he made five starts
and posted those numbers five and three
with the 3.76
era got him looking
2ks in the inning a man stranded at
second
and there is freddie peralta making his
first ever start against the cub
which i was unaware of you just feel
like he's been around long enough to
start against chicago but this is number
one
javi baya is at the plate narvaez wants
it down and away
and he hits the spot little roll over
ground ball to silgaard
that's a great start for peralta command
with everything thus far three up three
down
got a three in one count you don't want
to do too much here you want to make
sure
you pull this ball and put it in play on
the ground if nothing else
hayward hits a ground ball to the right
side it will drive in the run fielded by
hera throws out hayward but
he does exactly what you just finished
saying ron he put the ball in play
on the ground to the right side chatwood
has
been very sharp here early on he has
struck out four
walked one has yet to allow a hit
and he gets yelled for the second time
that's five
for tyler well and it's that pitch again
when we were talking
to tommy hadavy about this hybrid cutter
slider he's just
he's zeroed in on the this inside part
of the plate are off the plate down and
in
smoke strikes out swinging three up
three down four
shutout innings for tyler chatwood it
remains cubs one milwaukee nothing
comes a lead man on in this fourth
inning wilson contreras
driven deep right center that ball will
get into the gap
schwarber on his way to third he's
coming around
and he will score
wilson contreras with a run scoring
double
two nothing talked about the elevated
fastball if you try to pull that pitch
you're gonna pop it up he stays on it
so good when he when his approach is
alley to alley
a good aggressive send here by will
vettel at third base
with nobody out he might have been
inclined to throw up a stop sign but he
uh
kind of read it and said let's go for it
two on nobody out a run in
base hit to center contreras coming
around
and he will score without a throw it's
three to nothing
corners two for two
base hit to right
hayward toward the plate
and they add another run it's four to
nothing and still
nobody else ian happ the batter the
infield back
first and third half lines a base set to
center
coming in to score on the play as nico
horner caratini stops at second
the bottom of the order doing a
tremendous job here in this fourth
inning
and orlando arceum with a swing and a
soft little
basin in the right brewers are going to
get on the board here
and it's finally a run scoring base hit
to be a playoff contender although i
guess everybody is this year that
is deep half is gonna make the catch up
against the wall
for out number two what a play by ian
happ
chatwood has not needed a lot of help
here today from his defenders but ian
half
turns in a sparkling defensive play
[Music]
contreras launches and it will get way
out of here
back of the bleachers for willie and
it's six to one two out lightning there
from wilson contreras who was so good
throughout the summer camp
was in the inner squad games and the
exhibition games
two extra base hits for him here today
double in this long home run
the 3-1 is hit high and deep to left
yellets will watch it girl
ian hat with the second homer of the
series
and it's eight to one
just showed you the great play in center
field and who contributes with his
second hit of the day
[Applause]
cracks one in the air deep left field
this has got a chance and it
is gonna be gone opposite field home run
anthony rizzo cuts lead nine 9-1
another hefty hefty hefty home run
rizzo stroking it to the opposite field
and they're roughing up their former
teammate
justin grimm yeah their old buddy has
hung a couple breaking balls and he has
paid the price this thing this the
breaking ball up and out over the plate
anthony didn't
try to pull it he just went with it
high fly ball into deep right center
into that jet
stream now more leaps and he made the
catch what a grab
just below the basket albert almora jr
robs morrison of an extra base hit
lofted the left coming in as half cubs
win cubs win 9-1 the final
and they begin the season two and one